all right we got to talk about these
folding phones for a minute because it's
changed a lot since the last time we did
so the first ever folding phone from
OnePlus came out this week it's called
the OnePlus
open not a very good name but a very
very very good first gen foldable I've
been using it for about 3 weeks now I
got lots of good things to say about it
but it's actually I feel like it's so
good that it's actually resurfaced the
old question in my head from a couple
years ago which is what's it going to
take for regular people to actually
start buying folding phones because yeah
I like this phone and I'm going to go
ahead and guess that some other
reviewers will like this phone too and
some enthusiasts will like this phone
and this video may even get a lot of
views but none of that necessarily
translates into regular people just like
strolling into a store or going online
and choosing to buy one of these so
first things first the details of this
phone so this is a super high-end phone
in every way and the design is
particularly well considered you can see
it's basically the same size as a normal
phone on the outside this is a 6.3 in 20
by9 cover display just over 1080p it's
ltpo down to 10 HZ and it's an absurdly
bright 2,800 nits Max brightness between
these pretty thin bezel so this actually
does take the crown now for the
brightest display I have ever seen in a
smartphone and I'm going to go ahead and
give it the co- crown for best foldable
to use wall closed alongside the pixel
fold so I still think that pixel fold
has it's more reachable it has better
button placement since it's a bit
shorter but there's no question this
feels like a flagship phone on the
outside even if you never even open the
thing there's also a bunch of design
touches I really like the flat sides all
the way around super clean the alert
slider is also back so it's way up there
at the top of the phone which is kind of
tough to reach but I love that it works
exactly as you'd expect same as previous
OnePlus phones that had it and the power
button also doubles as the fingerprint
reader which we've seen with lots of
these full FS as well it's awesome and
then around the back mix bag I would say
I'm not the biggest fake leather on the
back of a phone person it gives me like
Samsung 2016 Vibes um but at least it
does hide fingerprints this is the other
color now it's it's a green it looks a
little bit cleaner but really the
feature is the gigantic camera bump uh
and yeah it's pretty crazy looking but
but it also happens to be exactly where
my index finger rests on the back of the
phone so it's like a nice little shelf
that feels really natural when using the
phone while closed so I kind of really
like it for that also the LED flash I
guess it couldn't fit so they shoved it
up in the corner for some reason but
then you open this thing up and it just
it becomes so obvious why they waited so
long to do their first foldable it looks
nothing like some of the other first gen
folding screens from years ago it's got
this huge 7.8 in corner to corner ltpo
3.0 display that again goes up to 2,800
nits and down to 1 Hertz even bezels all
the way around got the whole punch in
the top corner and honestly one of the
least visible creases you will see in a
folding phone in 2023 now I think it's
actually debatable if we can technically
call this their first foldable phone
because while OnePlus hasn't made a
foldable yet uh their sister company
Oppo clearly has so I wouldn't be
surprised if this took a lot of tech
from them actually there is another just
released Oppo phone called the Oppo Find
N3 and it's the same as this but the
point still stands with this screen on
you literally don't see the crease at
all and Screen Off you still kind of
have to look for it and then yeah you
hit the angle where the light reflects
off of the middle of the phone and then
you can see it but this is one of those
phones that looks really good from
almost every angle you would actually
use it and then it also has one of those
hinges that stays at whatever angle that
you hold it at so if you want a sort of
a 90° angle or a little bit more open or
closed you can do that and then it has a
nice satisfying spring-loaded clap shut
it's also it's impressively thin it's
not the thinnest one I've ever seen but
pretty good it's lighter than you you
would expect it's actually if you put it
on a scale it's basically the exact same
weight as an iPhone 14 pro when they're
doing stainless steel so just a regular
phone weight so it's an impressive piece
of Hardware but then the software for
this one is OnePlus so it's it's oxygen
OS 13.2 and it's got all kinds of little
tweaks and little features that power
users are going to love because let's
face it this is a phone for power users
people who are going to love the
continuity features between the open
screen and the closed screen so once
you're done using a big app you just
close it like this and then swipe up to
pick up where you left off on the
outside screen if you want to uh just
like the pixel fold it's going to mirror
your home screen set up automatically
between the cover screen and the inside
screen so if you if you change something
like move a folder or a widget or an app
on one and then switch to the other it
will have also moved from there too
keeps them a little bit more organized I
kind of wish I had the option to change
that since this is Android and I am a
power user but nevertheless that's the
way it is but then there's also a ton of
multitasking Fe features on the inside
screen for having multiple apps open at
once so you can have obviously one app
open full screen and that looks good for
a surprising number of apps it'll
stretch them if they're not natively
built for this but then you can have two
apps side by side and then you can pick
a third app to get in the mix then
they're all just sort of next to each
other in this triple panel View and you
can move things between them really
quickly or if you pinch out with four
fingers you can see all of all of the
apps at once so between that and the
dock with all of your apps and recent
files it's just a very well-considered
hub for sitting down and just getting
stuff done like I feel like when I sit
down and open this phone I'm about to be
really productive and get a lot done
this phone the OnePlus open honestly it
nail as a phone it Nails all five of my
pillars of a great smartphone great
screen great battery great build great
performance great camera and I'm not
being generous with that stuff it like
actually Nails all of that stuff like
you already heard about the great screen
and the fact that they match each other
so well inside and outside is already
pretty great there's also great
performance super highend specs
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 16 gigs of fast Ram
512 gigs of ufs 4.0 storage I mean the
pair of 120 HZ ltpo displays have a
240Hz touch sample rate it's super
responsive and I mean the whole thing
feels very future proof and then you
also heard about the build quality which
I'll revisit that in a second but then
battery life has also been excellent
with this 4800 mAh battery and 67 watt
fast charging although it just skips
wireless charging for some reason which
is like the most OnePlus thing ever uh I
think it adds like no cost and no weight
and no thickness but yet they leave it
out when all the other competitors have
it anyway all right fine but then this
huge camera module on the back kind of
implies high-end cameras but you can
never really be sure until you test them
and sure enough this house blad camera
setup is pretty decent it's got this new
stacked sensor for the primary sensor a
3X telephone photo and an ultra wide I
found it's it's pretty good most of the
time although it's not very good at
freezing motion which is fine if you
take photos of still subjects but the
second it's people or animals and those
things start to move uh then it can be
kind of hard getting a shutter speed
fast enough to freeze that stuff you
basically have to switch to action mode
which there's a button for and that
works by cranking the shutter speed way
up as expected but then ISO starts to
get a little high high enough that
photos are now a little noisier a little
worse looking so just that's unfortunate
and by the way this isn't one of the
Five Pillars but I also found that the
microphone on this phone is actually
quite good they're usually not this good
I was pleasantly surprised but it all
comes together in a really nice phone
that I think a lot of people including
myself are going to really like using so
the question is why do I think people
aren't buying folding phones that much
if they're this good turns out a phone
can hit all five pillars of a great
smartphone and not be a great buy for
everyone necess necessarily and so it
really comes down to three things I
think number one is still price number
two is the durability question and then
number three is just the power user
problem so on price this phone is
$1,700 us that is a lot of money to
spend on a phone no matter how you chop
it up into monthly segments or staggered
payments it's just a lot right it's
literally twice as much as an iPhone 15
but guess what that's literally right in
line with its folding competitors like
the other two folding phones available
in the US pixel fold $1,800 Samsung zold
5 $1,800 so this one's actually kind of
a bargain that's the most obvious thing
holding these back CU they're still so
expensive but then number two durability
is also questionable at best now of
course they do all the testing that they
can and guess what they've got ipx4
water resistance which is nice and they
have a durability rating for a million
folds of the hinge and that's great but
then what about these dead pixels that
have started appearing at the bottom
middle of my screen right around the
hinge I've had this one for 3 weeks and
babied it and this is already starting
to show up on mine doesn't mean it's
going to be bad for everyone but that's
not great and I suspect it's not going
to happen on non-folding phones but the
third and final reason folding phones as
great as they've been getting aren't
necessarily translating to mainstream
success is that they're power user
phones they're folding and unfolding is
a power user feature and power user
features as much as we love them don't
sell a ton of phones we figured this out
many times when LG spent years and years
making some of the most manually
adjustable cameras in the smartphone
world and now they don't make
smartphones anymore and we still have
Sony who can't stop making professional
cameras in a smartphone body but their
sales are putting them in danger of the
same thing and Asus Zen phones are
absolutely incredible right now for
enthusiasts like myself but they've
already thrown a head fake clearly
they're not doing super well either I'd
honestly be willing to bet without even
being able to look into anyone's books
that the folding phones are not at the
top of sales in any of the lineups of
any of the companies who are making
these things probably the most
compelling folding phone Hardware I've
seen yet is this honor phone this
thing's called the honor magic V2 bro
look at this thing this it's super thin
it has all the right things and all the
right places it's got a 3D printed
titanium hinge cover barely shown any
crease when it's open thin bezels nice
screens all the way around somehow it
has a 5,000 mAh battery inside and
high-end specs like playing with this
phone over almost anything else over
even Samsung's has helped me appreciate
what folding phone Hardware can actually
be but despite all that awesomeness it
still has those kind of obvious
downsides for a regular person to
probably not pick it over a regular
phone the price it's like 1,400 bucks
the durability
potentially compromised we don't know
and then even though it is thin and
awesome it's still just like the the
power user thing of wanting to carry a
slightly thicker phone around and have
that extra ability is not something
everyone sees as obvious and something
they actually want we are starting to
finally see some of those flipping
phones come at least closer to the
mainstream because they are lower in
price the the zflip 5 is down to a th000
bucks from Samsung and Motorola just
launched their most affordable flip yet
the Razer 40 I think is launching soon
at 600 bucks so that seems to be getting
closer but it's just we need a lot more
of that stuff so folding phones are
simultaneously very evolved from their
Beginnings just a few years ago and yet
still have a long way to go so I guess
until we get there more fun for us nerds
thanks for watching catch you in the
next one
peace
[Music]